- Forrest, go away!
- Okay.
I just--I have something
that I need to explain to you
that's gonna change absolutely
everything, okay? Just please.
Please, this is the last thing
I will ever ask of you.
- What is all this?
- This is all gonna
help you understand
what's happening, okay?
- Great. Come on in.
- All right. There's a lot
to walk you through here,
and all of it is important,
and it's hard
to know where to start.
The first clue that I had that
something was wrong was this.
This is a list
of every single review
that has ever been
sent in to the show,
and all of the ones
that I've done are circled.
Do you know who circled them?
- Grant?
- Yes, exactly.
He told me it was all random.
Keep your voice down,
please.
You're gonna wake
up Eric and my mom.
(Forrest voice-over)
I laid out all of my evidence
to Suzanne.
All the pain.
My review of having
a perfect body, okay?
Oh, [bleep].
What is this?
And my penis has never been
the same since then.
No. [bleep].
Is it still like that?
I had the thing taken out,
but it's still weird.
It's like there's too much skin
now 'cause the implant came out.
Let me just show it to you
so you have a sense of--
Move on!
I don't want to see it.
Fine. All right.
Fine, fine, fine.
I don't think that that was
any normal magic eight ball.
I think Grant
was controlling it.
- Okay.
- Why did a pillow fight
have to become so violent?
And it turned into
a [bleep] bloodbath.
This was supposed
to be a show about life, okay?
Grant turned it into a show
about death. My death.
That's what's happening here.
And so I'm gonna tell him
I have figured it out.
This is not what I signed on
for, and I am out of here,
and I'm going back to my wife
and my kid,
and I'm going back
to my old life.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Forrest,
I think it's really simple.
You signed on to
an insane television show,
and then you constantly
put that show above your needs
and the people
that you love.
I'm just not seeing
this evil plan.
The only person that you need
to be afraid of is yourself.
Oh.
[scoffs]
I'm gonna prove I'm right,
and then I'll be back!
(Forrest voice-over)
If I was going to convince
Suzanne of my conspiracy theory,
there was one more thing
I needed to know.
Why? Why was Grant
trying to destroy me?
What had I ever done to him?
This question plunged me deeper
into the darkness
where I made a shocking
and upsetting discovery.
I've been doing some research
here on HTML, ww.google.com.
There's no trace of Grant
anywhere on the internet
prior to 1995.
It's like he does not exist.
Now, 1995 happens to be
the same year
that this woman supposedly
married a Chinese guy
and disappeared to Hong Kong.
This is Gretchen Edelberg,
and she had a really big crush
on Suzanne when we
were all in college together.
You see where I'm going
with this?
Gretchen, okay, Grant.
Gretchen, Grant.
Gruh, Gruh, Gruh.
She didn't move to Hong Kong.
She got a sex change.
He loves Suzanne so much,
after all this time,
that he's gone
completely crazy.
Get out of here,
you son of a bitch!
(Forrest voice-over)
Now that everything
finally made sense,
it was time to confront
the monster in his lair.
Of course
he's not gonna open that gate
because he knows
that I know the truth,
and he's too much
of a [bleep] coward.
Hey, you're too much
of a [bleep] coward
to look me in the eye--
oh, [bleep, bleep]!
Oh, God.
All right.
Come on.
Let's go.
- You [bleep] monster.
- Forrest.
I know everything now.
[bleep].
- What a nice surprise.
- No.
- The guy's will bring it in.
- Ah, [bleep].
I've figured it all out,
and I'm quitting the show!
Again?
Everything you've tried
to hide from me
is out in the open now.
You've ruined my life
for the last time, Gretchen.
You bitch.
This should be good.